reinvention to us means changing how the
world thinks about mental health
you know we traditionally think about
mental health as people in crisis mode
so there's very much a stigma associated
with it I've seen close ones struggle
with with things like depression we've
all had our own stress and struggles in
everyday life that we all deal with and
so it's something that's always been
kind of front and center for me I grew
up exposed to the medical environment my
parents are physicians and I knew I
always wanted to start a company
my sister who actually had just finished
Harvard Business School at the time was
super snooty she told me I had to move
to this place called Silicon Valley so I
booked a one-way ticket about six years
ago and I worked at a couple different
digital health companies along the way
and that's where I had a front-row seat
to the problem we're solving no one was
taking a more proactive and preventative
approach to mental health and part of
the reason why preventative mental
health is so important is because we've
had this kind of shift in changing
culture and society and how we work
we're now tethered to technology and as
a result of that we're actually all at
higher risk for things like depression
and anxiety than ever before we're not
robots yet right so the next
billion-dollar idea is in someone's head
and so making sure that we protect our
brains is is incredibly important for
the productivity of different workforces
we've had this kind of shift where
people want to take a more proactive
stance at their mental well-being I
think a large part is that it's starting
to be more D stigmatized more people are
speaking out about struggling with
things like depression who are
successful and in the eyes of the rest
of society and so seeing people in the
limelight saying yes I struggle with
depression and I'm still successful at X
Y Z has now kind of caused this shift
for more people to be open and talking
about it there's no one-size-fits-all
for mental health so everyone kind of
has their own way to approach it but
making it that it's a priority for every
single individual that's what our
mission is and that's what our goal is
[Music]